here we go
two bits of casting news for the next
Man of Steel movie aka the Justice
League movie aka the Zack Snyder fest
with a lot of weird casting one of them
I'm gonna breeze right through cuz it's
the easy one one of them is for Alfred
jeremy irons is cast as Alfred which is
cool I mean Jeremy Irons is a good actor
I think he'll do a fine job it's Alfred
at first though I was like are we doing
the forever evil or Jeremy Irons has
always been kind of villainous to me is
the voice of scart and I remember the
will the voice and Mufasa is also the
voice of Darth Vader so it doesn't
matter what is Jeremy Irons good actor
if he's not in Dungeons & Dragons and
now he is Alfred fine the second bit of
news is who's going to be Lex Luthor
you've heard it by now Jesse Eisenberg
is going to be Lex Luthor all right it's
one of these moments guys the casting
for this movie has been weird to say the
least Ben Affleck as Batman everyone's
like what I was like I don't see it man
written for the guys maybe they see
something I don't say then gal gadot who
I called gal gadot but it's gal gadot
again I was like she's too skinny she
can bulk up my problem isn't her as
wonderful moment problem is the fact
that Wonder Woman is even in the movie
but I was like hey maybe the powers that
be see something I don't see or whatever
we'll see now Jesse Eisenberg as Lex
Luthor it's likely there's always a
moment in something like this where you
have to draw a line in the sand and go
you know what I need to make a stand my
disclaimer I will say I'm not a casting
director maybe they see something I
don't see I get it that means that from
where I'm standing not only do I not see
it I advocate that it's just not just
not good
again nothing against Jesse Eisenberg he
was nominated for an Oscar good actor
but now remotely Lex Luthor at least not
the Lex Luthor I was hoping to see in
this movie I know the argument is he's
the same age as Henry Cavill first of
all on that I always thought Lex Luthor
was older than Superman so still if he's
the same age he's still too young second
of all it's not about how old the actor
is it's how old the actor can seem
appear and act in terms of what the role
requires that he's playing Andrew
Garfield was 28 he was playing a
teenager for the amazing spider-man
why because he doesn't look 28 he does
an act 28 Rachel McAdams and Mean Girls
well than to hurt when he's playing a
high school student why because she
could pull that youth off Jesse
Eisenberg is 30 and he seems like he's
22 which would be fine if they want to
do a Lex Luthor beginnings kind of thing
like Lex
Luthor's it's really smart kid maybe his
dad Lionel still alive calling him a
dick being like make something of
yourself then jesse eisenberg lex luthor
at the end gets the drop on him and he
takes over the company and now it sets
up four sequels that's just not I don't
think that's where they're going with
this though cuz if they are I feel like
that'd be a waste of time we already saw
that in small though which will this
brings me up to another point why
not get Michael Rosenbaum to be a Lex
Luthor I know he already did in a TV
show and they want to do something new
with a new actor because in movies they
just don't do that like if you play a
role in a TV show and they make a movie
adaptation some years later that's
completely detached you don't get to
play that same role in the movie usually
that being said I still think Michael
Rosenbaum is the best Lex Luthor ever
put on any screen ever the dude was
awesome I just like his kind of Lex
Luthor he's smart he's methodical he
plays Bach on the piano while sipping
his scotch cool right no Jesse Eisenberg
I feel like the kind of villain he would
play it would be like it's like mclovin
and kick ass and kick ass too I think
Jesse Eisenberg would be a good Riddler
yeah sure young Riddler Edward nygma
just starting out he's kind of nerdy has
a sweater vest
he's smart so he makes traps and messes
with Batman sure awesome but the Alexa
Luthor the guy who owns the city oh not
that you were my zombie land review what
did I call Jesse Eisenberg a
twenty-something year old socially
neurotic awkward guy who kind of reminds
me of Michael Cera and Andy samberg's
love child and I still hold that when
you say we're like that's exactly what I
see that person I don't think would be a
30 year old Lex Luthor 18 to 22 year old
Lex Luthor still finding his way has a
grudge against his dad who's still alive
sure but an established Lex Luthor who's
like no that alien doesn't have a place
on this earth I don't say it we had
rumors of actors who would be much
better Lex Luthor's like Bryan Cranston
as Lex Luthor was one of the rumors at
one point awesome I'm hoping for
something like that which is funny I
feel like Zack Snyder talked to his
casting director and he was like all
right we need someone to be a Lex Luthor
who's she to be catching director was
just like well sir the fans are really
hoping for Heisenberg and quite frankly
I think he'd be perfect Mitch Schneider
was like oh right that's so perfect
Jessie Heisenberg of getting them on the
phone right now that's not really what I
meant already ringing sorry ringing
we're gonna make this for it oh it's
just not what I meant
awesome hey Jesse Heisenberg what's up
and now here we are in this situation
there was a fan trailer with someone cut
together a fake Superman trailer
with Bryan Cranston as Lex Luthor is one
of those things where you watch it and
you're like that is awesome
I want that yeah it's gonna be great and
now just the Eisenberg and it's just not
know I did all gonna be like that I know
I want to give the guy the benefit of
the doubt I really do but I feel like
all the casting in this movie Zack
Snyder or somebody trying to go for long
shots you know it's like oh yeah just
like Ledger's Joker no one had faith in
that many killed it we're gonna do that
with every main character in this movie
which you can usually do that with one
if you have everyone else that people
have faith in that one oddball we were
like is that gonna work and then the
movie does and that person does kill it
you're like ah cool it work but
everybody that's just risky Jesse
Eisenberg has to know that this is gonna
he's gonna get backlash it'd be like if
I was cast to be Emperor Palpatine in
Star Wars Episode seven I don't know if
he were coming back or some I'd be
like I'm not the best choice for that
but I'm gonna get backlash I'll do it a
can yeah I know I'm not the best one for
it so I like to think that he knows that
so in the end the casting of this movie
I don't get any of it so for Jeremy
Irons as Lex Luthor I love that dude
he's beast all the casting has been so
strange to say the least that maybe
there is a pattern to it they're
obviously going off the rails so the
entire movie will be so obscure that it
all fits together in an obscure world
and does work in its obscure way or it's
all just going to be terrible which is
pretty much what I just said ultimately
the thing that will save this movie for
me is a trailer I need to see a trailer
I need guys Warner Brothers people if
you're watching this in the trailer do
not hide Lex Luthor show us because
that's the thing if we have faith in
that then he'll be like ah sure Affleck
can pull off Batman no problem just
advice from a fan so Jesse Eisenberg as
Lex Luthor what do you think about that
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you